well let's move on to the gays because
we can't go as day in america without
talking about the homosexuals as bill
o'reilly
calls him uh it's actually been a pretty
good week for the gays again
because uh two more senators this week
democratic senators have now
endorsed marriage equality uh we got
heidi heitkamp that's not a made-up name
and senator joe donnelly they jumped in
also a couple republican senators for
the first time jumped in this week so
the only four
democratic senators left that are
against marriage equality
are joe manchin of west virginia mary
landrieu of
louisiana mark pryor of arkansas
and tim johnson of south dakota so i
guess we'll start
are these four is this all politics at
this point like is this just
are they all having real revelations and
are they really evolving or is this
purely
partisan politics and you got to get on
board with the democratic team
no i think it's good like a guy like joe
manchin holding out you know
for the he's representing that part of
america who still
thinks gayness is gross so good for him
that's really all it comes down to it's
right it's like this old antiquated
thinking and the new
and it's just even um you know a lot of
religious people now are um
they're not they're on board with it
they get that it's not something
who would choose i know the whole thing
about choice is what frustrates me the
most i think a lot of
people out there that are bigots are the
way that they are because
of ignorance right they genuinely think
that this is like perversion
and that gay people make that decision
at some point in their lives and they
have some sort of
illness and and all you have to really
do is sit down and educate people and
let them know what the reality is and
when it comes to these democratic uh
representatives
at the end of the day no one wants to be
on the wrong side of history you know i
was talking to megan mccain and we were
tweeting you know
not a big deal we're twitter friends um
yeah yeah and
look megan mccain has some politics that
i don't agree with but the one thing
that i love is she has been an outspoken
supporter of gay rights
and uh you know she said you know one
day when i have kids i'm going to be
proud to say that i was on the right
side of history
and i feel the exact same way and i hope
that these representatives feel the same
way
are some of them doing it for politics
absolutely and i think that that's lame
i think sometimes you have to stand up
for what you truly believe in as opposed
to playing politics
isn't it crazy that at this point let's
say these four in their heart of hearts
really don't think gay people are that
evil but they played that card to get
voted in that they could potentially now
be voted out
because they're gonna do the right thing
isn't that doesn't that just show how
crazy politics really is
um well it shows how kind of maybe
backward their own individual states are
you know the rural states seem to be the
ones that are tough to come along and so
wherever people bump up against other
people it seems like progression
happens right that's where progressives
come from cities and it's just uh and
that's i think
kind of shines a light on what's wrong
with the way we are
not only our whole political system that
people
in states that have no people living in
it have just as much power
as states that have elect so it's it's
not one man one vote in america
and i think that we need to take a look
i mean i don't know if you can ever take
away someone's representation
but it's weird that you would have two
senators and one congressman right
that's not right so you're saying that
the senator from uh montana where they
have seven people shouldn't be quite as
powerful as the guy from i think barbara
boxer let's say here in california
that's exactly what i'm saying yes
yeah uh i'm i'm interested in would be
nice if we had a parliamentary
you know kind of government here instead
of the one we do i think we get more
stuff done like canada
yeah by the way canada's had gay
marriage and uh their country then
hasn't crumbled yet
yeah and don't you love how every time
something good happens in america like
we get health care
all the lunatics say well i'm going to
move to canada where they have
healthcare yeah
or we're going to have gay marriage here
i'm moving to canada where they have gay
marriage it just shows you how really
dumb these people are
but what do you think about is there
going to be a point where it's too late
so like these four
democrats that are left like can we just
give them like a cut off date like you
have till wednesday yeah
and then after that you're not getting
any credit whether you do it or not you
know what i mean like i feel like we
need some sort of cutoff
otherwise we're just dragging these
people for all the wrong reasons i feel
uncomfortable
giving them credit now because if you
were an opponent
of marriage equality or you know even
gay acceptance for instance if you were
an
opponent of that how do you just like
evolve on that issue so freaking quickly
so i'm not buying that i mean i think
that probably in their heart of hearts
they do
believe in uh marriage equality uh for
gay people
but i just hate that they played the
politics and it makes me not want to
give them any credit
politicians playing politics is there
anything worse i can't i'm
gambling i um but i will see you know
talk about not giving people credit you
know
uh i thought it was funny to hear before
the election people said we have to vote
for barack obama because he
he came out for gay rights he only only
took the first black president three and
a half years to realize
we shouldn't discriminate against groups
of people right wow don't break your arm
patting yourself on the back there mr
o'brien right and he basically only did
it because he got sort of cornered into
it yeah
on me so that's so it's it's weird to
see people
um especially someone who's an
african-american
who should be more sensitive to that
issue still play politics with you i'm
going to pander to the people who are
bigoted
for a little while and then i'm going to
i'm not going to do anything gay rights
among the african-american community
is a very touchy subject as well because
a lot of black people are conservative
they're religious
so uh even though it i totally believe
it is a civil rights issue
you know some black individuals don't
see it that way well there's a religion
there's the whole dl
phenomenon where these guys are secretly
gay
and you know it's not accepted but
they're doing it you know
the dl hughes syndrome i think it's
called that we just outed him
but don't you think it's funny that they
like some people think it's like well
you know i think the state should vote
on it it's like you
shouldn't vote on something yeah how
about i think if we voted on regular
marriage i don't know if that would pass
either
exactly or if we had ever voted onto
interracial marriage that
you know or people being allowed to vote
the minority should not
be subjected to the vote of the majority
in fact
when when they got rid of the law
banning uh interracial marriage
only 25 of the country backed that so
they they went against the will of the
country to do to enforce the
constitution which is nice to see they
do that sometimes
absolutely final point on this do you
think there's a little bit of a risk in
that we put so much focus
uh on social issues in politics like
there's so many important things going
on with the economy
and north korea and all that stuff and
yet so much of our media is just driven
by the social stuff do you think that's
an act there's actual risk
in that in terms of the discourse i'm a
little biased because
i do an entire hour of social commentary
news
but i will say that i do think that it's
extremely important
because this has a lot to do with
liberty and personal liberties
so um we have to cover the social news
because we have to make sure that
there's equality for all groups of
people
if if there is a case of like for
instance uh we just recently did a story
about
a high school in georgia that has never
had
a racially integrated prom they've
they've had segregated proms
all these years even after brown v the
board of education i mean it's insane
and so it's important to talk about
those things because you want to make
sure you protect people's rights
um and when it comes to uh you know
marriage equality
it's we're starting to see progress and
part of the reason why we're seeing
progress is because we're shining a
bright light on this
issue and i'm biased also because i
don't like armenians but the point is
bonovos.com is the official outfitter of
the reuben report enter code trr20 for
20
off your first purchase